have you ever streamed a game through
PlayStation now pretty soon you'll have
fewer options for where you can do it
I'm Tony this is a GameSpot news update
and make sure to subscribe to be the
first to hear about all of Sony's
changes PlayStation now services are
being removed from many devices
including ps3 Vita Vita TV and all Smart
TVs with the PS now app leaving only ps4
and PC the official statement reads
after thoughtful consideration we
decided to shift our focus and resources
to ps4 and Windows PC to further develop
and improve the user experience on these
two devices this move puts us in the
best position to grow the service even
further if you use any of the above
devices we want to give our heartfelt
thanks for your support and we hope
you'll continue with us these changes
will go into effect on August 15th with
some TV models losing access on April
1st and no it's not an early April
Fool's joke
if you're a fan of PS now on PC maybe
you like are glowing RGB PC build over
on GameSpot and for all the latest
playstation news you're already in the
right place